The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MITOpenCourseWare@OCW.MIT.edu.
KEN NAKAYAMA: The
social mind, let
me see if I can just go
through these slides here.
One might ask the
question on the origin
of human intelligence.
OK, I just want to give a
little bit of background.
Nancy summarized my
career very nicely.
I started out recording
from retinal ganglion cells
and animals.
That was a very long time ago.
And I was kind of
into reductionism,
trying to understand how retinal
ganglion cells determined
how we see certain
psychophysical phenomenon.
So what am I doing
here talking about some
of that social processing?
Well, it's been a long
time ago, so in your career
you do different things.
But as I'll say in
a moment, I happened
to read an interesting paper.
I was in the University of
Tokyo library kind of bored
and I found a book.
And I found an article,
which I'll talk about that.
Didn't change my life,
exactly, but it reoriented me
towards this social processing.
And you'll see there's many
different ways of studying.
I think the realization
that social processing
and the human mind are
really very inextricably
connected opens the door
for kinds of investigations
that I think are sort of really
open-ended and somewhat limited
just by your imagination.
So I sort of
encourage some of you
with that bent to
think about this.
Since I study vision I
will just talk a little bit
about the visual
system as a preamble.
And I was studying vision
about 50 years ago.
And I think I was sleeping
for about 10 years.
And all of a sudden I found
out something interesting.
Here's a picture of
the visual system
when I started graduate school.
There was the motor system,
the somatosensory system,
coupled sensory system.
And vision was that
area 17 V1 in the cortex
I think I slept a
little bit and all
of a sudden I woke up and
oops, little bit past 1970.
Almost the whole half of the
brain in the back and the front
was devoted to vision.
You probably had
lectures by that.
And so I think that's really an
important fact because the fact
that the brain is very visual--
I mean, that's human.
So maybe in mice it
might be different,
they may be it's old fashioned,
or something like that.
But for primates I think
it's very important.
You probably learned about
the different systems.
That the posterior
part of the brain.
There's a lot of anterior parts.
David Marr said, anybody
heard of David Marr?
OK, David Marr said vision,
where is what by looking,
what is where by looking?
I just want to say it's
way, way more than that.
The visual system-- I mean,
if vision's half the brain,
that's just a
pretty, puny problem.
So we have to think
of all the things
that the visual system might do.
And we really haven't
thought of them.
Well here's some more
pictures of a visual system.
So, it's a little bit like, it
started over here on the west
and you go east.
It's sort of like
Russia going all the way
to the Pacific Ocean.
Vision system really expand.
I think it's kind of
slowed down recently.
I would just say the visual
system is very big in primates.
And if it's half
the brain, well all
the other stuff, like
greed, sex, power, music,
all that other stuff.
It's about the same.
So, that means that we just
don't really understand.
That's a lot of stuff
over there on the right.
That means, on the left,
we don't know squat.
So just have that
in mind, there's
plenty for you to do
as young scientists.
So I don't know.
It must be--
This is a very tiny list.
It's lots of things.
It's David Marr kind of thing.
So it's more than that.
I'm going to talk about
visual motor control.
I'm a psychologist.
For some reason, I
think a lot of our--
Roger Sperry said 70 years
ago that the ultimate arbiter
of your mind is action.
I mean, if you don't do
something-- if we can have--
I mean, I studied
perception most of my life,
but if you don't do
something, you're
not going to pass your genes
on to the next generation.
So action is it.
Psychologists, they don't
study action at all.
That's like, they've
forgotten that.
So I just like to put
a plug-in for action.
There's people who
study the motor
system that are kind of picky.
So and even if they are, and
don't let you into the field,
it's important field.
I think you should
push your way in.
I think it's extremely
important for navigation.
Most animals live in a
widely extended space.
They know how to go
home quickly if they're
trouble and things like that.
I'll talk a little bit about
some kind of animals like that.
The range of area that animals
go over is astonishing.
And so I think the understanding
of animals in their natural
environment, there's
lots of work on it,
but I think it's-- a lot
of it's quite mysterious.
But I'm just going to talk
mostly about social perception.
And this is the paper
I read a long time ago.
I never met this guy.
His name is Nick Humphrey.
And he wrote this paper, I
don't know, maybe 30 years ago,
and I just happened
to come upon it.
And it was in a book.
And he said-- he
was not very nice.
He said, experimental
psychology in Britain
have tended to regard social
psychology as a poor country
cousin of their subject.
So basically, he
was putting down--
but he really wasn't
because he really
said something different.
He said, wait a second.
And he sort of turned
psychology upside down.
And he said, you know, actually,
the social part of intelligence
is the thing that
drives everything else.
I mean, he might
be overstating it,
but let's see what
he says, here.
Oh, I'll come back
to that in a minute.
The intellectual
faculties of primates
have evolved as an adaptation
of complexity of social living.
For better or worse,
styles of thinking which
are primarily suited to
social problem- solving
color the behavior of
man and other primates
even towards the
inanimate world.
So he's sort of making the
implication when I said,
where does
intelligence come from?
One of the sources
of intelligence
are the nature of
the social world.
And it's a quite a
complicated world here,
because this guy, Dunbar.
You've heard of this guy.
He sort of-- I'm not sure
this is a really good study,
but what he did was he made--
he got the size of the cortex
of lots of different primates
and he made some
kind of estimate.
I have no idea how he did this.
How many animals
were in their troop.
But you can sort
of imagine, if you
have a different social
group, it's not just--
it doesn't just go up by N.
Because let's say, you know,
it's not just how many
people you have to deal with.
Those people deal
with other people
and they might be
plotting against you.
So in other words, the number of
permutations of social behavior
really--
I mean, it's only
one other person,
it's not too complicated.
As you get like six,
two people might
be plotting against the
third one over there.
All kinds of possible
things happen.
And as some of
the primatologist,
if you read some
of the accounts,
there's planned murders of all
kinds of people in the top.
It really looks a little
bit like the Medici's back
in the Machiavellian
intelligence.
Doesn't sound so weird.
OK.
So basically, the idea
is that intelligence--
we have to think of intelligence
in the social world.
I'm just scratching
the surface here.
So let me just talk a
little bit about prediction.
That's kind of what we think
one of the hallmarks of science
is, prediction, right?
So what are-- in what
area is prediction better?
Any thoughts.
Suppose I took a rock and
threw it down the mountainside.
I couldn't do squat, right?
I mean--
AUDIENCE: Well, you could
do all the measuring, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but nobody's
going to do that, right?
AUDIENCE: That's
what I'm saying.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Biology, I mean, we
know-- for example,
we know that behavior of
atoms, we can't really
predict the behavior of
atoms over long trajectories,
but we can show that, you
know, at a certain date,
maybe next year, at Woods Hall,
people from all over the world,
including Nancy, are going to
show up at 9 o'clock, here.
We can predict that.
And we can predict things
like my alarm clock
is going to go off tomorrow at
a certain time because I set it.
So what I'm trying
to talk about is
kind of a point that Dan Dennett
made, who is a philosopher.
Who, I think, has really made
really seminal contributions,
at least to my understanding
of psychology to a large extent
because he really talks
about explaining things
at different levels.
This is another--
I started out as a
reductionist in a sense,
but let me just give you, give
you a sort of a thought, here.
Have you ever noticed
that when the moon is
setting over the Western
sky, it's the new moon.
It sometimes seems
kind of the whole moon
seems to be illuminated
a little bit.
It's not, it's not
just that crescent.
If you think of the, if
you think of the sun,
it should only be
a little crescent.
So why do you see the rest
of the moon filled in?
Well, there's the possibility
that the sun reflecting off
the earth, which then sends
light back to the moon.
That's an explanation.
Do we need to know
about photons?
Do we need to know about
duality of waves and particles?
No.
That's an explanation.
That's all I'm trying to say.
Some explanations are
pretty darn simple.
And in science, I
think we're looking
for any fun, interesting
explanation we can find.
So I think Dennett has
nailed it to some extent.
OK.
So he basically has three
levels for predicting behavior.
The physical stance.
I mean, if we have ideal
situation of Galileo dropping
his balls as a
flight that, assuming
there's no resistance
to air and stuff
like that, we can
make nice predictions.
Biology and engineering, we know
that you know, seven minutes,
the coffee is going to
be ready, because that's
what it was designed for.
But then he's got something
called intentional stance,
which is in order to really
understand what people are
going to do,
Churchland would say,
well, we go in to look
at their nervous system.
We record from their
neurons and stuff like that.
But Dennett would say,
no, we can't really
use the physics thing or
even design, we just use
some other heuristic,
which is very explanatory,
what people desire and
what their beliefs are.
If we know that, we
really can understand
what they're going to do.
And of course, your grandma knew
that or your great grandmother
knew that as well.
So but these are really great
ways to understand people.
And so I think
that we can't just
turn our backs to these things.
And I think Dennett--
the question is, and we
might come back to the end.
What's the sort
of scientific sort
of status of some those
types of explanations.
Are they scientific?
Or what are they?
Maybe if we have time,
we can talk about that.
OK.
I'll skip that part, here.
So I sort of feel,
just as-- what
I'm saying is it's a non-
reductionistic way of looking
at thing-- you should
open your mind.
And actually, CBMM or
brains, minds, and machines
is kind of your kind
of condition to that
because some people come
from computer science.
I mean, you can't really
understand a computer
in terms of atoms and molecules.
You really can only
understand the computer
at some kind of a higher level.
So I'm just telling
you, that's fine.
If you're a neuroscientist and
want to reduce it to synapses,
things like at, good try, but
it might be difficult to do.
There are many other
valid things to do.
But one of the things to do--
let's just examine some things
about them and explore them.
I think, as I say, there's
so many possible things
in this realm.
Doing anything, I mean, people
have all kinds of principles.
My approach in the area,
this kind of area of science,
or any science that I've
done, is to develop new tools,
and then helps you explore.
OK.
So there's lots of
things that humans do.
But what I want to stress in
the first part of this talk
is that our human social
behavior is really not
unique in many ways.
There are very, there
are very important things
that animals do.
And I'll talk
about them shortly.
Animals, really are very social.
There are certain
animals like octopus,
apparently is not very
intelligent, not very social,
but by and large many
animals are very social.
Doesn't explain
everything but it's--
I think we share
some core things.
And if we can understand some
of the behavior of animals
or why they're social and how
their social mechanisms work,
I think we have a treasure.
So the area of animal behavior
is very underfunded area
right now.
I sort of feel--
I just happen to like
to watch nature videos.
And I'll show you
a few, you'll have
to indulge me a few of these.
But I sort of feel
these can be more
important than
careful psychophysics
because I think they
open your mind to things
that you may not
have thought about.
So I'm a kind of
devoté of these things.
OK.
So do animals have an
intentional stance, etc.,
kinds of things like that?
We don't know.
Here's a fun video I think
maybe half of the audience
have seen this video.
And maybe I'll show
the whole thing
because I think we have time.
It was taken just by chance.
I think it's been
a TV program now.
And I think it's got
like 50 million viewers.
It's about different kinds
of animals interacting,
their social behavior.
It's about animals that you
do not think are that smart
and things like that.
Ungulates.
I don't know.
I don't know what
buffaloes are exactly,
but we've never thought
of them as highly
intelligent or social.
AUDIENCE: That is
a huge buffalo.
AUDIENCE: That's a huge buffalo.
AUDIENCE: I love this.
AUDIENCE: Is it little?
AUDIENCE: They're crouching.
AUDIENCE: She's crouching.
AUDIENCE: She's
going to get eaten.
AUDIENCE: Oh, my god.
Oh, my god.
[INAUDIBLE] Oh, she's going
for him, she's going for him,
she's going for him.
She got him.
AUDIENCE: Jeez.
AUDIENCE: Oh, she did.
She got him.
AUDIENCE: Ladies.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: No, the
lions have won.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but look
at all those buffalo.
AUDIENCE: --Buffalo down.
AUDIENCE: They're like,
go and try chase the lion,
but I think they're too late.
AUDIENCE: They're going
to chase [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Look at
the teeth, Jay.
AUDIENCE: You're too late.
You're too late.
AUDIENCE: I think because he
cannot believe what's going
here.
There's a big barrier
between lions, crocodiles,
and buffaloes.
AUDIENCE: Look at them all.
AUDIENCE: Whoa.
AUDIENCE: He swatted at
him and kicked at him.
He's kicking at him, look.
He's kicking at him.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I
mean, buffaloes is basically
used to [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: And in
deed, [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Oooh, they
got him surrounded.
AUDIENCE: And that one's--
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
AUDIENCE: Chasing-- go on, go.
Chasing--
AUDIENCE: You got the
lion [INAUDIBLE] right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Dave, can you get the peace?
AUDIENCE: The others
are doing that.
[INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Never seen that.
AUDIENCE: I've never seen--
AUDIENCE: The
calf's still alive.
AUDIENCE: It is?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's trying to get away.
It's standing up.
AUDIENCE: It is.
It's still alive.
PROFESSOR: There's
much more to this.
There's many other videos
about lions and buffalo
finding a layer of baby
lions and the mother is gone.
And they just kill all the
lions in there for revenge,
or whatever it is, your
interpretation, I don't know.
But anyway, so I'm just
trying to tell you.
I'm not going to show you
more, but in the lectures,
there's going to be a
number of videos here.
I'll show one more I think.
But I think this is--
I don't know, I think
you can see this is
better than an experiment, OK?
You really get--
to me, it really
showed me a kind of, a kind
of a social organization.
A kind of-- are these
animals conscious?
All of these kinds of
questions here that I think you
should think about.
OK.
So on my website, on
the lecture there's
going to be some other
videos that you can look at
and things like that.
I won't do this one, here.
This is a very
interesting video.
Some of you might
have seen it as well.
I don't exactly know
what the origin,
I won't show it here today.
But it's about a--
on the web, it says
monkey teases tiger,
it's a gibbon, or
something like that.
But it's a really amazing show.
It goes on for
about five minutes.
We're given just swinging
around and making
himself ready for attack.
He runs along the ground,
the guys are chasing,
it's like playing tag.
And he runs up a tree
and he jumps over
them and he their tail
and he grabs their ears.
There are two lions,
two tigers there.
And he's just putting his life
at risk, but he's doing it.
Maybe that's that the theory
is, maybe that's his territory.
He doesn't want those
people around there.
But it's pretty amazing.
So just Google monkey
you know, teases tiger.
You'll see the full video.
It's a pretty damn
amazing video.
Another video that is fairly
interesting and this is just--
just shows you.
This is a guy named
Jaak Panksepp.
I used to be on a study
section with this guy.
I couldn't figure out what
this guy's talking about.
This was many years ago.
And he's now an expert
on laughter in rats.
And he tickles rats and
they follow him around.
And can you hear them laugh?
No, you can't hear them laugh.
So he got this bat detector
which takes ultrasonic sounds
and brings it down to
our frequency level.
And you can hear
the rats laughing.
So try that out as well.
So you can do that
in your spare time.
So he's got some very--
Oh.
This one is kind of
interesting, War.
One of the interesting
things about--
We have sort of a whole field
called evolutionary psychology.
And what's the reasons why
animals might cooperate a lot?
That's what we're
talking about here.
These are really-- a lot of
these things are up in the air.
And there's a lot of
debates, but one possibility
is, if animals
cooperate, they can
deal with a rival group
of animals who might
be taking over their territory.
Animals have private property,
you might call it territory.
They don't have contracts
or anything like that,
but it's pretty close.
And if they have territory
that they have and there's
another group that
has territory,
there's going to be conflicts.
And why not call it war?
And humans have had war
for many generations.
And I just like to show
a little bit that--
these videos are
incredible videos.
The guy's name is
Timothy Clutton- Brock.
He's a ethologist at the
University of Cambridge.
He studied many different
kinds of animals.
And these meerkats--
there's been a,
there's actually been a TV show.
Have you ever
watched the BBC show?
Anybody here?
It's a BBC show and it's
gone for four years.
I mean, how long
did Dynasty go for?
Or all these ones
that you guys watch?
I mean, four years of this
life of these animals here.
And the really interesting
thing about-- they're
about one foot tall
and they run in troops.
This group of animals
is really interesting.
There's more animals
than you think.
These are female-
dominated societies.
There's a alpha female.
And she has, she
has many children.
And then her
daughters are supposed
to take care of her
kids, not their kids.
What happens is sometimes
the daughter wanders off
and some Romeo was
coming around and they
had babies and stuff like that.
That daughter has to really
be nice to the mom to stay.
Usually she's
banished and she dies,
or she joins that other troop.
There's so many
different things.
And these animals-- you
can see these guys, here.
See the investigators
on the BBC show--
these animals somehow have
been totally inured to humans.
So they're doing all their thing
and people are just walking
around with their cameras.
So this is-- you don't have
to set up a laboratory,
you just go out there.
And you have to go to
the Kalahari Desert.
But I think that this is
an incredible research
enterprise that's been
going on for about 10 years.
One of the things is they--
I think, in many ways, it's
one of the most studied
social animals because the
Kalahari Desert is just open.
You can see everything.
One of the things they do is
they dig down into burrows.
And so when they're digging way
down-- they can eat scorpions.
They're not, they're
not bothered if they
get stung by a scorpion.
But if they're down there
and there's hawks going over,
they can just pick them off.
So they have these sentries
and things like that.
So they sort of double up--
and then they have babysitting
co-ops where they're
teenagers that--
they have these
burrows underground.
But of course you can't-- if
you're growing up as a meerkat.
By the way, meerkats have
nothing to do with cats,
but they're somehow
related to mongoose.
They're sort of a little
more in that category.
But anyway, they have a
baby sitting kind of thing
where they let the
kids out on there.
They play a little bit and if
it gets strange, they run back.
And so there's a whole
babysitting thing
because every day they have
to go out and forage for food.
And they go very long distances.
The territory of these
meerkats could be
as much as a square millimeter.
That's amazing.
Just think of these
animals, this big,
going over a square
millimeter, a kilometer.
That's territory.
So what we have, of course,
in the human situation--
DOCUMENTARY NARRATOR:
Moments later,
the rest of the whiskers
return from foraging.
From the brow of
the hill, they see
that their home has been
overrun by the [INAUDIBLE]..
The rival group spot
the owners of the burrow
and the angry whiskers waste no
time in commencing the attack.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DOCUMENTARY NARRATOR:
--Straight towards the whiskers.
They're going to defend
this piece of territory
as if it's their own.
A bloody fight is inevitable.
One of these sworn enemies
will have to be in [INAUDIBLE]..
The [INAUDIBLE] a hasty retreat.
PROFESSOR: The good guys won.
What I'm going to tell
you is a pale sort
of version of all
that stuff but I
think we have to study
stuff in the laboratory.
So a lot of my interest
comes from the work
of Nalini Ambady who
is a colleague of mine,
long ago in
psychology department.
And so what--
we're going to go--
I'm going to talk about
humans now because that's
what I've been able to do.
I'm not-- But I do
think that we really
need to look at all different
parts of the animal kingdom.
But she did something
that's really
quite interesting as
a social psychologist.
Mostly people have been handing
out questionnaires and people
how-- what do you
think about things?
Social psychology has
mostly been about attitudes
and had a rightful good
history about prejudice.
And how people who have--
a lot of the social
psychology came out of the--
was stimulated by what happened
in the Second World War,
the atrocities and
things like that.
How could people do
things like that?
And so those are really
important things.
And you read about them.
But she did something
sort of more
at an everyday level in
a sense, and just take
pictures, very few pictures
of different people.
And just see what people
get from these pictures.
So clip, movie clips.
And basically, she
did one thing and just
had people rate
teachers that they--
this is at Harvard.
We had teaching fellows
and they were just
talking to their class
and things like that.
And then students just rated
them, what they thought,
how good a teacher they were,
just on different adjectives.
And that really predicted
the student ratings
of the whole course.
In other words, 10 seconds was
able to predict the ratings
of the whole course.
So remember that
when you do teaching.
I'm hopeless, but who knows.
Anyway-- Basically, here's
another thing they did.
OK.
There's that.
Gaydar, you can tell if
somebody is gay or straight
or something like that.
It only presenting the thing
for about 15 millisecond.
I find that hard to believe.
If you look at a video, two
people talking together,
you can tell whether they're
friends or strangers.
There was a really
interesting one.
This is really-- outcome is
you have an interview or tapes
between doctors and patients.
And you can outcome variables
like whether that doctor got
sued or not.
You can have people
rate, have adjectives
and it's sort of
like, a little bit
like-- you can think of
doing machine learning,
just taking all those
adjectives and then
sort of predict whether that
person is going to be sued.
You can see just by this a
kind of a crowd-sourcing way
of dealing with all
kinds of real world,
social, significant things.
OK.
So I've worked a lot
on face recognition.
That's a very important
thing in the sense
that in order to negotiate
our social world, if you
can't do facial recognition,
you're in trouble.
I work a lot of people
with prosopagnosic.
Oliver Sacks.
May know who Oliver Sacks is.
He's definitely prosopagnosic.
And if he's at a party,
he's a little bit lost.
But he's a-- he has so many
other charming characteristics
that he can manage.
People come up and talk to him.
But you can imagine,
if you're not
that charming,
witty, funny person
and you don't
recognize people who
you're supposed to
recognize, you're in trouble.
One of the subject
I worked with, she's
a quite a well-known author.
And she goes on book
tours, she's happy,
and she is she does
very, very well.
She has a problem
with face recognition,
but she can't really
recognize a lot
of the guys in her departure.
She teaches-- She's an
English literature professor.
There's about four
guys in our department.
She can't really recognize
one from another.
That makes social
interactions very difficult.
So we all are experts
at face recognition
but I've studied something
called face blindness.
But I just want to step back
because the thought occurred
to me.
This is one thing
that's really--
we've just published, not
myself, but my collaborators,
we've--
well, I'll come
back to that later.
It's called face recognition
under early stress.
I'll come back to that later.
Remind me.
OK.
So over the last 100
years or so, there's
something called acquired
prosopagnosia which
means that, I think, the
best case was, I think,
World War II victims,
the German soldiers
in the Second World War.
And those people, you could
tell they had face recognition
problems because of course, they
were able to recognize faces,
and later, they
weren't able to do it.
And so-- but more
recently, and I've
studied hundreds
of these people,
and we've actually signed
up thousands of them.
People-- we just we
put a website out
and we basically have studied
huge numbers of people
who are just naturally occurring
people who can't recognize
faces very well at all.
And we've got about
6,000 registrants.
We really don't test
them that much now,
but we can test them on the web.
As Nancy mentioned, we
do that kind of thing.
Just some testimonials from
these people, one or two,
just shows the
problem they have.
This week, I went to the
wrong baby at my son's daycare
and only realized he was not
my son, blah, blah, blah.
So in an audience
like this, you don't
have to identify yourself since
you got so many people who
are STEM people.
STEM people sometimes
have these problems.
Usually if I give a lecture
to an audience like that,
somebody will come
up and say that's me.
So this is a lady
I know quite well.
She's got a PhD in
differential geometry.
She's a mathematician.
She has lots of problems.
She is one of the
few [INAUDIBLE]
that I think is kind of
mildly on the spectrum.
But most of the people I've
studied are not autistic
or Asperger's in any way.
But a lot of people
have problem.
I claim it's a visual problem.
It's not a psychiatric
problem or a social problem,
but it does lead
to social problems.
And with Brad
Duchaine, I've studied
these people quite extensively.
And the thing that--
I just want to say, in
order to study them,
we developed a face
recognition test.
I got into the testing
business in this way
because the tests that were
out there weren't very good.
They were really bad.
I mean, they were--
I won't go into
how bad they were.
So we spent three or
four years just making up
a test, which is now used
widely around the world.
And I don't want to go into
the details of the test
but it basically
enables people to sort
of over-learn about six faces.
It's a little bit like
natural face recognition.
It's not-- I think
it's a very good test.
I won't go into why
and things like that.
And it gets harder and harder.
But I just want
to say that we've
been able to characterize
these prosopagnosia people.
But somebody all of a
sudden shows up and says,
well, I'm not one of them.
I'm super.
So we've study those
people as well.
I won't go into detail.
We made a lot of
studies about them.
Just a couple of testimonials.
I pretend I don't
remember people
because people think
I'm stalking them,
or something like that.
So now we've studied
half a dozen of them.
And now we're studying a much
larger population of them.
I would-- All I'd like to
say is these people are as
good as prosopagnosics are bad.
They're really-- but we haven't
found that many of them.
We've probably identified
about 30 of them
and we've been looking.
And we give them much harder
tests of face recognition.
Some of you, if you
can recognize all four
of these people before they
were famous, I'll come up
and you might be one of
our people, but I doubt it.
Most people think they're
very good at face recognition.
When we test them,
they're not that good.
So nature versus nurture.
Make sure I don't go
over my time, here.
You know, most of
you are not psychol--
how many people are
psychologists here?
OK.
So you know that
there's some experiments
called twin studies
where you study
some characteristics
in monozygotic twins
and then different,
dizygotic, dizygotic twins.
And so the idea here is
that they sort of share
the same family environment.
Of course, each
person's different,
and they have a different way
of dealing with the family
and stuff like that.
But that's the best we can do.
But if you can show that the
correlation between twin 1
and twin 2 is very, very
high, and in our case,
it's going to be extremely high.
In fact, it's just as high if
twin 1 took the test twice.
That indicates-- and
then if you compare it
with dizygotic twins, there's
a real difference there.
And that's what we've shown
essentially, is that--
I'm just saying, the test
reliability is very good.
It's tech has a R of
0.7, which is very good.
And we had--
There's 350 just random people
who took the test twice.
But now what you can do,
we have this online way
of doing research where we can
just have people come up and--
the real hard thing
in twin studies
is not to get monozygotic twins,
it's to get dizygotic twins.
Dizygotic twins don't really
care about being twins
that much, but monozygotic
feel, hey, I'm a twin.
My wife is a monozygotic twin
so I know all about this.
So we have something called
the Austrian twin registry.
And we pay them and
they-- a very nominal fee
and they do our tests online.
And what's really
interesting, we
found if you correlate
twin 1 and twin 2,
they have to be obviously
the same gender.
The correlation, you'll
see here, is 0.7.
It's just as good if the
twin took the test twice.
That's pretty darn amazing.
And the dizygotic is 0.3.
So in this particular
situation, I
think we've shown
to our astonishment
that the ability of this
face-- the ability to learn
new faces is almost entirely
heritable, whatever that means.
I mean, it's a
technical definition,
but it indicates that your
ability to recognize faces
is strongly controlled by
other factors than experience.
And that's when I want to bring
up this childhood adversity
thing, here.
Laura Germine has done a
very large survey of I think,
over 1,000 people who were--
and these are things-- we had
trouble with the IRB here,
but people talked about all
of their horrible things that
happened to them,
childhood sexual abuse,
neglect by their
parents, all kinds
of things that are really
bad when you're growing up.
And then we did a lot
of tests on the web.
And everything, all our
tests showed real deficits
in cognitive abilities, in
even emotion recognition,
but there was no deficit
in ability to learn faces.
So that's pretty--
so what I would
like to suggest is that somehow
we're sort of topped out.
We have enough
experience seeing faces
and we've reached our asymptote.
That's just a point that
might be of interest here.
So another thing
we've done recently,
I don't have any data here, but
we just got it paper accepted,
was to show that using
the same sort of paradigm
of monozygotic and
dizygotic twins
that face
attractiveness is not--
there's no genetic component
at all, basically zero.
So here's a face attractiveness
test that we've cooked up here.
Here's a bunch of faces.
You have a bunch of
cards, you sort them.
That's all you do.
You get the mean ratings
for all the faces
and then you rate the faces.
And I'm going to
say, OK, you're--
let's say that upper
left- hand corner,
that's one person's ratings
versus the mean ratings.
That's a correlation of 0.74.
The next person's 0.91.
That's really unimaginable
to me that, that person
there's correlation with
the mean rating is so high.
And look at these ratings.
They're very, very high.
Of course, these are
Harvard undergraduates.
They all have the same
kind of mentality.
Perhaps that's maybe
that's the point.
But the correlation
with the mean, this
is just from one of my courses.
It's unbelievable.
The correlation, the
agreement of who's attractive
and who's not attractive
is astonishing.
So what we did was we had
these MZ versus DZ twins
and had them rate them.
We have a kind of a jingle.
We say, how quirky are you
when you're a beauty judge,
or something like that
because our web site,
we don't pay anybody.
In the twin study, we do, but
we like to make the tests fun
and interesting to the people.
And we, most of
the time, give them
feedback as to how they done.
So all I'm trying
to tell you there
is that we don't see any genetic
component there at all when
you do the monozygotic
and dizygotic twins, here.
Gender versus attractiveness.
Where you give a bunch of
pictures to people and you say,
which looks more
feminine, more masculine?
You do that with girls and
then you do it with boys.
Which was more
masculine, feminine?
Those are very
reliable ratings also.
It's hard to see but female
attractiveness correlates very
well with the gender judgment,
male attractiveness doesn't.
Actually male attractiveness
is quite robust.
People can agree on
male attractiveness,
but it's not the gender axis.
Maybe you know, 2000 years ago
it was machoness or something
like that.
But in our society, it's agreed
upon but it's a little bit
mysterious.
Alex Todorov has
published a paper
on this, which I
don't understand.
But he says he explains
it, but I'm not sure.
But that's an interesting
area of what constitutes
male attractiveness.
A fellow, who is an MIT
student, Richard Russell,
found one of the
things that is related
to female attractiveness.
It's basically contrast,
facial contrast.
Not how dark you are,
but your facial contrast.
And he just found
that if you just
measured the
contrast of pictures,
you find the female
average contrast is
higher than the male contrast.
And if you take a
picture like that,
which is an androgynous person
here, and you just change--
you have the same picture and
you just increase the contrast,
the one on the left
looks more female.
And maybe that's the reason
that Richard thinks that this
is the basis of some cosmetics.
And he works with
a cosmetic company.
He's not doing--
OK.
So the final part of this
talk, I'd like to talk about
is that, which I'm more
involved in right now.
Is I sort of feel that
most of social psychology
is involved in kind
of asking people
questions and things like
that about sociology.
But as I said in the
beginning of the talk,
I feel that the
realm of human action
is something that has
not been investigated.
So I just feel it's something
that we need to probe.
And what I would
like to argue is
that by studying
our human actions,
we can actually reveal
our social perceptions.
That's kind of the point here.
So most of you have been
in very crowded places
and you don't bump into
people and stuff like that.
And there's many
reasons for that.
But basically it's
pretty amazing
that people, pretty much,
don't run into each other
in very crowded and when
they're very rushed.
And there are many situations in
which your social interactions
with people are extremely
skilled in a sense,
in different kinds
of dancing or fencing
or different kinds of athletics.
So I claim this is
the domain of what
I call rapid social perception.
So how can we study
rapid social perception?
Well, I'm OK with
all these things,
showing movies and
stuff like that.
But we've sort of put
it into the laboratory,
in a more discrete fashion just
because we can study it easily.
Now one of them is
that most of you
watch the World Cup,
is the penalty kick.
It doesn't happen all the time,
but every once in a while,
it happens.
And you know, that's a
really dramatic moment.
And of course, you
have to predict
which way the kicker
is going to go ahead
of time if you're the goalie.
So we've set up something which
was sort of parallel to it
which I call the
lab version, here.
So here's the kicker, here.
But the job is not to kick
the ball into the area,
but just touch
target left or right.
That's your job.
That's all you do.
Go boom, boom.
That's it.
That's the trial.
So it's very simple.
And we tell people it's a game.
If you are up to the game--
The blocker-- if you get
there within 150 mil--
we sort of titrate it to match
the skill of the two people.
But it's a game.
Harvard undergraduates
love the game.
They get tired
because a little--
but there's no problem.
Harvard undergraduates don't
know each other usually
so they're not friends
or anything like that.
They just, they
just come in there.
So I think there's a
movie here as well.
Let's see if I can
get this going here.
Oh, here, go this way.
OK.
So this is the game, here.
Is it moving?
There you go.
Here.
That's it.
That's the game.
I like pretty
simple experiments.
OK.
So but then what we do is
we just measure the finger
position of the two players.
You can just buy these things.
They are off the shelf.
They're not very expensive.
The one I had like you know,
a couple of thousand dollars
these days.
This is very low tech.
It measures the
position of the fingers
and at a high precision, very
fast, and stuff like that.
You can buy this thing.
It takes a while to get it
going and stuff like that.
So basically, we can
map the trajectories
of the various people.
And you can see that
they're well- behaved.
And just like that.
So what's interesting
is the timing here.
So the kicker goes like
this and the blocker--
so you can make little
measurements, here.
And so we can just measure the
horizontal positions, here.
So the blue is the kicker
and the red is the blocker.
And so obviously, they
can't do at the same time.
But the reaction
times are interesting.
What's that difference in
the launch point, there.
And what we found was it
was actually very low.
You can see it there.
Some were as low as 100
milliseconds but it's 150--
it's lower than choice
reaction times normally.
So if you take-- if you
could have a button box
and put a buzzer or
something like that,
choice reaction
times are usually
about 100 milliseconds longer.
So what's going on here?
But maybe choice reaction time
isn't a really good choice.
So what we did was we took--
we actually can take the
position of the finger
and map it on the screen.
And we have a little experiment
here, where you actually--
instead of playing
against a person,
you just, there's a little
dot that zooms up there
and you do that.
So maybe it's that--
the fact of that.
So we do this, and
that's the experiment.
And it turns out
this experiment,
we're about 100
milliseconds longer.
So in other words, if you're
playing against the human
being, that's on average
about 100 milliseconds.
So you are faster when you're
dealing with human being.
I will just skip over
some of this stuff, here.
And again, there's
no learning here.
Basically, it's just, it's flat.
So what's going on here?
We think what's happening here,
and this is the punch line,
I'll just elaborate
a little bit more.
You think all through
your life you've
seen people do different
kinds of actions.
And if you do any
kind of action,
there's all kinds of
postural adjustments.
I was just talking to one of
the guys in Emilio Bizzi's lab.
If you're sort of in
different kinds of sports,
if you lunge like that,
what's the first muscles
that contract?
Anybody want to know?
Your butt.
Because that's to maintain
your center of gravity.
So there's all kinds of--
I'm not saying people will
watch you know, their butts
and stuff like that.
But when you make
any kind of motion,
it's your whole
body is connected.
And somehow we have
knowledge, implicitly of this.
So what's going on here?
We talk about 90
milliseconds or so.
What section of the
body informative?
Well, in a sense this is
kind of-- you just block off
different pieces
and stuff like that.
And we just, we have
all different kinds
of ways we can just--
limited.
And we do-- we did all kinds
of experiments like that.
And basically, if
you show all, there's
an advantage, just the
torso or just the head
and there's the computer,
it's all over the place.
That the information
is all over.
But that's not
unreasonable because when
you're doing something,
all parts of your body
are connected.
So there's quite an advantage.
I think basically, oh,
this is your question.
We're moving this stuff.
So we have-- we call
them cut videos here.
So what we do is we
play a video, here.
By the way, we now
have shown that people
would behave exactly
the same to a video
than they do to
the other person.
So that makes the
life a little simpler.
So there we go.
There's-- I don't know if you
can tell, but essentially,
nobody, except a couple
of star athletes,
could tell what it was.
And it turns out, in the
cut videos, in other words,
you don't have that
preparatory stuff.
You just have all that
if the person is still,
we don't even know
what those motions are.
But basically, they're
100 milliseconds slower
than the cut videos.
So another thing
is, oh, we even did
stuff-- we did another
series of experiments.
Well, maybe it's eye movements.
And basically, we just
did some more blocking.
And shoulders are important,
you can see, here.
Oh, I didn't show that.
I don't have the data there.
But basically every-- even
the head, there's a little--
all of those, the first
five, except the last one,
were very good.
Even the last one, you
can hardly see anything.
You just see the
head then you see
the eye movement is a little
bit of an advantage, even there.
OK.
So basically, what I'm
trying to say more broadly,
is that our ability to
understand humans probably more
to predict what
they're going to do
is something that we've
learned somewhat unconsciously.
We're going to do a lot of
machine learning of what
parts of the body it is.
And all kinds of
stuff like that.
I'm interested in
if you people have
some ideas of what
other kinds of things we
can do to generalize this.
But I think it's
an area where we--
it helps us understand
all the kind of knowledge
that we do have of
other people that we
can weed out in ways that are
very subtle, but reliable.